ce
allô allô bonjour je suis ravi d'être là
avec vous et aujourd'hui je suis venu on
est dimanche
donc dimanche est un jour férié donc je
pense que c'est très approprié pour le
sujet dont on va parler aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous
parler vous avez entendu une partie du
titre mais j'ai envie de vous parler
d'une grande grande grande partie de
votre vie alors je vous dis grande et je
pense que c'est encore plus que ça parce
que il ya des mariages qui dure moins
longtemps que notre vie professionnelle
moi je suis venu vous parler de travail
vous seriez moins que tout à l'heure
alors je vais vous parler de travail
parce que nous passons quarante deux ans
et demi à travailler et je sais que le
temps passant travaillera de plus en
plus et je travaille dans la
communication et dans la communication
inde est une des choses sur lesquelles
on se penche avant de vous proposer des
sujets des communications des publicités
c'est la logique des choses
donc j'ai remarqué le matin en croisant
des collègues en croisant des voisins en
croisant des gens ont peut-être en vous
croisant vous que tout le monde n'a pas
l'air très très content d'aller
travailler le matin je vous êtes
peut-être l'exception de la règle vous
êtes peut-être des gens qui aimait se
lever le matin pour aller travailler
peut-être néanmoins de façon générale
vous rencontrer des gens et vous disent
vivement soir et vous en rencontrez
d'autres qui vont vous dire vivement
vendredi la fin de la semaine et vous
allez aussi rencontré des gens qui vont
me dire vivement les vacances
et c'est surprenant parce qu'il ya aussi
des gens qui vont vous dire vivement la
retraite mais il ya quand même quelque
chose qui est bizarre vous avez des
enfants vous avez été enfant vous tous
vous avez tous et des rêves d'enfants
mais ce pas eh bien vous savez moi comme
vous quand j'étais enfant j'avais des
rêves et j'avais même des rêves de
travail j'ai eu l'ambition tour à tour
d'être aux plus petits aux plus petits
des souvenirs je me souviens j'ai eu
l'ambition d'être other personne ne sait
ce que c'est qu'un other alors je suis
gourmand donc quand j'étais petit
j'aimais bien la viande et j'ai associé
le mot hausse à viande et donc je me
suis dit tiens je vais faire aux heures
comme ça je serai régulièrement en
contact avec les choses que j'aime oui
j'ai un petit peu grandi donc j'ai eu la
phase cosmonautes eu la phase pompiers
puis un jour j'ai eu envie de devenir
aventuriers
ensuite j'ai grandi et l'ambition de mes
parents a grandi en même temps que moi
je grandissais de tailler et eux ils ont
décidé que ce n'était pas des métiers
sérieux et qu'il fallait absolument que
je fasse une carrière qui fasse bien
donc les carrières qui fasse bien
c'était faire du droit
et aujourd'hui je suis publicitaires
alors vous allez me dire qu'est ce qui
s'est passé alors voyez ce petit exemple
qui me concerne pensèrent beaucoup de
gens autour de nous comment se fait-il
que quand on est enfant on a des ailes
on a des envies de travailler comment se
fait-il que pour beaucoup d'entre nous
quand on arrive à l'âge on est censé
travailler si on fait pas exactement
notre rêve sont fait pas du tout notre
rêve
et finalement on a on est très éloignée
nos passions et le sujet aujourd'hui
dont je veux vous parler c'est justement
celui là voyez derrière moi il ya une
magnifique image c'est le symbole du mot
travail est donc en latin tripalium le
verbe trip à liart et qui signifie
travailler contraintes souffrance et
vous avez remarqué que l'homme qui est
derrière moi est un esclave d'accord
parce que le travail était liée à la
notion de l'esclavagé y avait que les
esclaves qui travaillait c'était pas
c'était pas magnifique donc vous savez
le temps a largement évolué mais on est
encore quand même très longtemps après
loin de nos ambitions d'enfants loin de
notre envie de réaliser ce qu'on avait
vraiment souhaité quand on était plus
jeunes et même on s'aperçoit avec le
temps que content grand deane au nobu ça
finit donc on sait par exemple dans mon
gars après avoir fait des études de
droit je me suis aperçu que ce qui me
passionnait le plus ce qui m'intéressait
le plus c'était le marketing et la
communication parce que à l'intérieur si
vous voulez de ces deux disciplines
il ya une petite part de psychologie une
part de sociologie et surtout quelque
chose que j'apprécie et qui à mon avis
est quelque chose qui peut nous perdons
petit à petit aujourd'hui c'est le bon
sens
je ne sais pas si vous percevez les
mêmes choses que moi mais notre monde
notre société ne fonctionne pas toujours
avec du bon sens on peut noter des
choses qui sont surprenantes voire
aberrant et je vais vous en soumettre
une tout de suite
est-ce que vous avez remarqué que
l'économie définit le type d'activité
dans lequel il est bon de s'engager
c'est à dire que aux recommande des
guerriers recommande de vous inscrire
dans tel domaine parce que ce domaine là
est porteur donc l'économie aujourd'hui
est celle qui nous aiguille vers un type
ou autres d'activité est entendue vous
allez me dire que parmi nous il y en a
qui décide mais rappelez-vous ce dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure ce qui eux
n'ont pas vraiment décidés se sont
retrouvés à faire un travail qui ne les
séduit pas alors qu'est ce qui se passe
on va rentrer 42 ans
souvenez-vous qui on peut aussi rajouter
temps des études puisqu'il est dédiée au
travail
donc on peut passer de 42 à 52 ans dans
un emploi qui est peut-être pas celui
qui nous est pas nuire à et là je viens
de vous laisser un et de vous lâcher
c'est moi pour le côté trivial du mot un
mot qui est déterminant vous avez
remarqué que dans notre travail
on est dans un modèle économique qui
nous dit il faut absolument être
rentable dans le coin est rentable il
faut rentrer dans les créneaux que
l'économie ne recommande à savoir les en
fonction des tendances et puis vous
allez travailler chaque matin avec cet
objectif de gagner de l'argent
ok c'est louable
néanmoins ace que ce bien est un gage de
satisfaction au quotidien pour pour moi
pour tous les gens qui ne sont pas là
aujourd'hui
cet après midi mais qui eux sont dans ce
cas de figure là ce qui veut donc dire
que je vous parlais bon sens tout à
l'heure la chose qui peut sembler un
petit peu surprenante c'est que
l'économie nous guide vers des tâches
que nous n'avons pas choisi mais le plus
pervers là dedans c'est que ces tâches
que vous n'avez pas choisi ne vont pas
vous épanouir alors évidemment très
modestement je m'adresse
particulièrement à à ceux qui ne sont
justement pas dans leur métier de
prédilection donc pour cela si vous
travaillez 42 à 52 ans dans un domaine
qui ne satisfait pas ça serait aussi
surprenant que vous puissiez avoir une
relation de couple avec quelqu'un
pendant 40 ans et qu'au final le matin
vous couchant ce soit difficile et que
le soin pendant beaucoup de chance est
difficile et le matin en brayant c'est
encore plus difficile
pourquoi une raison très simple vous
avez remarqué que quand vous faites des
activités qui sont épanouissante
on se lève le week-end pour aller faire
des choses qu'on aime on dort moins donc
on a une capacité plus ample à
développer les talents
et là dedans dans ce point là c'est le
point qui m'intrigue et que je voulais
vous soumettre aujourd'hui comment faire
en sorte pour mettre ses talents en lien
avec son activité la plus importante et
la plus longue de toute son existence
voilà ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
nous fonctionnons de cette façon là par
contre il ya beaucoup d'exemples de gens
autour de nous qui on a tous niveaux à
tous domaines parce que l'idée ce n'est
pas de créer une société qui soit fait
savez comme les rêves de nos parents nos
grands parents mais ça avocat l'idée
c'est quand même d'arriver à produire
quelque chose qui nous correspond
pourquoi j'ai vous soumettre
l'appellerait pas équation ce serait
prétentieux je vous soumettre une
formule lorsqu'on produit quelque chose
où l'on réalise quelque chose on aime
sommes d'accord on le fait avec plus
d'attention
donc on le fait avec plus de coeur quand
on fait avec plus de coeur la personne
qui veut vous acheter le produit ou qui
va bénéficier des services que vous avez
produit l'achètera avec plus de
satisfaction parce que vous savez cette
petite part dame ya une petite part dame
dans toutes les choses qu'on produit
cette madame c'est comme si elle c'est
comme si on oubliait dans la société de
production aujourd'hui de bien
on n'est plus dans l'objet est moins
dans l'âme et pourtant vous connaissez
je pense comme moi beaucoup de marques
que ce soit dans l'automobile que ce
soit dans les parfums que ce soit dans
la création ou dans l'innovation des
gens qui ont consacré leur passion à
réaliser des objets qui leur plaisent et
vous avez remarqué que toutes ces
marques sont souvent souvent
pardonnez-moi souvent des grandes
marques
c'est l'histoire d'un
sellier français et vous donner les
initiales élevé savez y fait des malles
et valises des sacs des choses comme ça
ce seuil est là aujourd'hui
oui vuitton pour ne pas le citer c'est
quelqu'un qui vend à travers le monde
aujourd'hui c'est là aux peluches des
chinois et bien c'est au-delà a réussi à
produire une entreprise alors qu'à la
base c'est un simple artisan et pourtant
elle est devenue aujourd'hui ce qu'on
appelle un artisan du luxe ce qui veut
dire que la formule que je vous soumets
était je met mon coeur à l'intérieur de
la chose que je produis est une formule
qui est incohérente elle peut pas dans
notre économie aujourd'hui parce que
justement vous dis que pour produire de
la rentabilité
la rentabilité se passe de vos patients
et pourtant quand vous vous acheter ces
produits vous les achetez avec passion
donc si on revient à notre sujet initial
à savoir comment faire pour travailler
sans avoir l'impression de travailler et
réussir
la question est simple si chaque matin
vous vous destinez à une action un
travail et un métier qui vous correspond
vous le ferez bien c'est une certitude
à partir du moment où vous allez le
faire bien vous allez enclenché la
fameuse formule dont vienne vous parler
cette formule qui dit que vous êtes
satisfait en le vendant vous êtes
satisfait en proposant vous savez c'est
là la fierté de l'ouvragé la personne
qui vous l'achète
elle aussi est satisfaite elle est
satisfaite parce que ya une perception
de la qualité
il ya une perception de l'investissement
au delà de la logique de l'objet
diard un ressenti savez cette part
d'humain qui vient s'insérer à travers
le le matériel pour lui il achète
c'est ce qu'il va faire il va en parler
autour de lui il va dire tiens tu sais
j'ai acheté et je vais vous donner un
exemple connaissez tous vous connaissez
le pas moi vous allez remarquer que y en
a de moins en moins en martinique
vous savez ces métiers qui produisent
des produits de qualité mais qu'on ne
voit de moins en moins ils disparaissent
parce qu'ils sont pas assez rentables
pourtant donc cette personne à qui vous
allez acheter ce bien cet objet ce
service cette prestation
cet objet d'art bessèges est content de
ce qui vous achète
partant de ce principe il va en parler
autour de lui et l'instant où il parle
autour de lui il ya un phénomène de fond
de l'appel de la fidélisation de
notoriété et de fidélisation
c'est pour ça que vous avez des marques
qui ont réussi parce que ça s'appelle un
succès destine et donc c'est basé sur
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
cohérent
voyez je vous parlais de bon sens c'est
purement du bon sens aujourd'hui dans
cette salle il ya des gens que j'ai
rencontrés dont certains développer
l'entreprise et je vois leur succès
aujourd'hui et je sais pourquoi ils ont
réussi ils ont réussi parce qu'ils ont
mis une partie d'eux ou partie de leur
âme
donc si on ramène à nos est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a deux alternatives on suit
ou en fait vous allez me dire c'est très
difficile de faire et c'est plus facile
de suivre c'est plus facile de suivre
les tendances et se dire tiens je vais
exercer tel métier ou tel métier parce
que je sais que là ils vont avoir besoin
de main d'oeuvre mais vous avez remarqué
que tous les innovateurs sont des gens
qui vont à la logique inverse de la
tendance savez quand les premiers
ordinateurs ont été créés et légendes
ibm rien ils se sont dit que jamais le
directeur de bnp m à l'époque n'a jamais
cru que les pc se développerait ça me
semblait complètement irréel mais c'est
l'histoire de steve jobs l'a créé si
quelqu'un qui n'a pas fait d'études
il a juste fait des études de
calligraphie et ses produits pourtant
aujourd'hui inonde le monde alors si on
ramène à notre proportion à nous ça veut
dire que nous aujourd'hui nous sommes
les acteurs potentiels de notre
épanouissement et ça c'est la première
étape induire introduire de l'émotion
introduire de la passion introduire du
sentiment dans nos vies professionnelles
ça paraît bizarre ça paraît incohérent
ça paraît illogique mais c'est tout à
fait logique
c'est simplement l'habitude qu'on a de
fonctionner dans un système qui nous dit
ne mélangeons pas la rentabilité et
l'émotion pourtant moi aujourd'hui je
suis convaincu c'est pour ça que je
souhaitais partager ça avec vous mes
expériences professionnelles m'ont
permis de rencontrer tous ces acteurs
tous ces gens qui avec leur coeur avec
leurs mains avec leur volonté ont réussi
à construire exactement la vie il
souhaitait donc aujourd'hui
j'ai un message on dit petite île grande
idée mon message est simple c'est que
changer notre économie commence à
changer par changer nos vies savez je je
crois de moins en moins que la solution
vient de l'extérieur je ne parle
clairement non
on a parlé on parle d' alternative dans
notre monde un monde alternatif et
parfois on est encore en train de
tourner la tête à gauche ou à droite en
disant tiens il ya un sauveur qui va
arriver qui va faire que le monde sera
mieux qui sera moins violent qui ira
loin de chômage qui aura moins de
problèmes mais la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vu le phénomène
de mondialisation fait que les
gouvernements ont très peu de pouvoir et
ils en ont moins en moins et vous savez
comme moi que ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
les gouvernements au moins de pouvoir
c'est que l'économie de marché et
d'économie la rentabilité aujourd'hui
s'intéresse à la croissance des chiffres
mais plus à la croissance des hommes
donc mon message n'est pas politique il
est dans la même logique que vous savez
une alimentation meilleur raisonnée ben
je pense qu'en fait on peut développer
notre existence avec une attitude
raisonnée je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
devenir en quelques semaines ou en
quelques mois vous savez comme le remède
miracle devenir exactement ce qu'on
souhaite
mais je sais une chose c'est que chaque
fois qu'on va détourner nos pas de ce
que nous sommes réellement de ce que
nous voulons réellement nous serons
moins fort parce que la réalité et vous
le savez au fond la réalité c'est ce
qu'on aime
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qui nous permet
d'être le plus fort l'apparence vous
savez je travaille dans la communication
donc je sais ce que c'est mais
l'apparence et je le dis toujours à mes
clients je n'arriverai jamais à faire
une bonne commises et une communication
ou à faire en sorte que vos produits
intéresse du monde
si à la base le produit n'est pas
suffisamment qualitatifs pour ça
pourquoi parce que votre bon sens
rejette les choses qui sont de moindre
qualité
moi je vous propose simplement
aujourd'hui et je le répète bien
modestement deux dirigeants n'ont pas
faire les choses qui nous permette de
vivre sans avoir l'impression de
travailler aujourd'hui le titre de ce
sujet c'est la passion créatrice
d'emplois moi je vous propose de revenir
quelques années en arrière de vous
souvenir ce que vous aviez envie de
faire je vous propose de vous dire que
tony vous le temps mais décidée
choisissez fait cette rupture fait
l'alternative choisissez autrement le
monde ne peut changer aujourd'hui que
parce que les gens changent long message
pour vous et pour moi pour que je me
l'appliqué c'est choisissez des choses
qui vous permettent de vous épanouir
parce que s'épanouir c'est réussi donc
le message pour conclure voyez le petit
garçon qui est derrière moi il était
libre ils étaient contents et c'est ce
qui lui a permis de s'épanouir
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
faire ce même choix dans notre activité
professionnelle parce que je suis sûr
d'une chose
une personne qui réussit attire
nécessairement d'autres personnes à ses
côtés parce que son entreprise croît
donc ma suggestion c'est d'ajouter de la
passion au coeur de l'économie vous
remercie
les